>> LIFE'S SPECIAL MOMENTS ARE
MEANT TO BE ENJOYED, NOT SPENT
WORRYING ABOUT YOUR IRRITABLE
BOWEL SYNDROME.
>> I'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> BUT RYAN'S SOLO IS COMING UP.
>> IT CAN STRIKE AT ANY TIME,
ROBBING YOU OF LIFE'S SPECIAL
MOMENTS, BUT NOW, THERE'S HELP,
WITH TREMFALTA.
TREMFALTA IS A ONCE DAILY PILL,
THAT HELPS CONTROL YOUR IBS,
INSTEAD OF IT CONTROLLING YOU,
SO YOU CAN ENJOY MORE OF LIFE'S
SPECIAL MOMENTS.
>> OH MY GOD, WHO DID THIS?
OH, IT'S EVERYWHERE, ON THE
WALL.
EW.
>> TREMFALTA WORKS BY SLOWING
YOUR BODY'S DIGESTIVE PROCESS,
DECREASING THE INTENSITY AND
VOLATILITY OF BOWEL MOVEMENTS SO
YOU CAN GET BACK TO WHAT REALLY
MATTERS.
>> WHAT DID I TELL YOU?
>> BECAUSE SOME OF LIFE'S
MOMENTS ARE TOO IMPORTANT TO
MISS.
>> STOP THE CONCERT!
>> KIDS, I'M SORRY.
SOMEONE HAS DONE SOMETHING VERY,
VERY BAD IN THE BATHROOM,
SOMETHING VERY DISRESPECTFUL.
>> WHO DID THIS FILTH?
>> DIDN'T GO SHUT THE [ BLEEP ]
>> CONSULT YOUR DOCTOR BEFORE
USE.
SIDE EFFECTS MAY INCLUDE --
>> SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH YOU.
YOU SICK SON OF A BITCH.
>> SIDE EFFECTS MAY --
>> YOU JUST LIT UP THE TOILET.
JUST LIT THE WHOLE DAMN THING
UP.
>> SIDE EFFECTS --
>> I HAVE KIDS!
OH, DAMN!
>> NEVER MISS A SPECIAL MOMENT
AGAIN.
>> IF YOU SAY ANYTHING, I WILL
DESTROY YOUR LIFE.
>> WHAT?
>> WAIT FOR MOM.
>> WITH TREMFALTA.
>> I THINK WE GOT A STAR ON OUR
HANDS.